ليست دائما مصدرا للبهجه والاحتفال
الساحره المستديره لها وجه اخر حزين ومفجع
مئه مشجعين فارقوا الحياه على مدرجات
وارضيات الملاعب في العديد من دول العالم
اثناء تشجيعهم ومؤزرتهم لفرقهم المفضله في
بريطانيا مثلا وتحديدا خلال ما يعام
النيران اندلعت في مدرجاته ملعب فالفراد
بمدينه برادفورد الحديثه وقعت خلال مباراه
بدوري الدرجه الثالثه راح ضحيتها 56 شخصا
واصيب نحو 200 اخرين بجروح هذه الماساه
الكرويه لم تكن الوحيده في انجلترا فبعدها
باربع سنوات وفي شهر ابريل لقيه 96 مشجعا
لنادي ليفربول هتفهم نتيجه التاسيس
والتدافع داخل ملعب مغلق في شفافيلد قبيله
نهائيا كاس الاتحاد الانجليزيه بين
ليفربول ونتيجهام فارسست الملعب كان حينها
مقتضا باعداد كبيره من الجماهير فقط طاقته
الاستيعابيه القصوى هذه الحادثه لم تكن
الاولى ايضا لمشجعي الريدز ففي بلجيكا عام
85 اندلعت اعمال عنف وشغب بين جماهير
يوفنتوس وليفربول قبل نهائي كاس اوروبا في
ستاد هايسل ببروكسيل عمل العنف هذه راحه
ضحيتها ثمانيه وثلاثون شخصا واصيب اكثر من
600 اخرين وفي نيبال عام 88 كان يتدافع
الجماهير ايضا السبب وراء السقوط اكثر من
90 قتيلا على ارضيه ملعب مدينتي 18
قتل نحو 82 شخصا نتيجه التدافع خلال
مباراه بين كواتمالا وكوستاريكا ضمن
تصفيات كاس العالم في اكتوبر عام 92
المشاهد الماساويه داخل الساحره المستديره
لم تقف على تلك الاحداث فقط ففي ما يعم 92
هرم مدرج بملعب فوريان في فرنسا ليقتل 18
مشجعا ويصاب اكثر من 2000 1300 شخص هذه
الحادثه كانت سببا في اقرار البرلمان
الفرنسي القانونا يمنع اقامه المباريات في
البلاد في هذا اليوم حزنا على الضحايا
عربيه كان الحادث الاكثر دمويه في مصر في
فبراير عام 2012 وتحديدا بمدينه بورسعيد
اعملوا شغب في نهايه مباراه جماعه فريقين
الاهلي المصري راح ضحيتها ثلاثه وسبعون
شخصا على الاقل واكثر من الف جريح ثم اعلن
الحداد الرسمي لثلاثه ايام وصدرت احكام
باعدام 10 متهمين رئيسيين والسجن لمده
متفاوته بحقيه 30 متهما اخر اما عن اخر
الكوارث في عالم الساحره المستديره فكانت
في اكتوبر عام 2022 في اندونيسيا ملعب
كانجرهان في ملاك شهد مقتل اكثر من 130
شخصا بعد مقتحم جمهور نادي ريما ارضيه
الملعب عقب خسارته من غريمه التقليديه
الشرطه اطلقت قنابل غاز على المدرجات وهو
ما تسبب في تدافع عن مميت وحالات اختناق
بالمئه ورغم كل هذه الحوادث المفجعه على
مر السنين تظل ساحره المستديره تسحر
ملايين عشاق كره القدم حول العالم